ed sheeran sets the record straight and
says he didn't quit Twitter they make so
much a big deal of in an interview with
the son published Monday the singer
revealed he'd recently quote come off
Twitter completely after being cyber
bullied naturally Ed's nineteen point
two million followers were upset but on
Wednesday he explained on Instagram
quote I haven't quit anything I'm just
not reading anything except Harry Potter
the shape of you singer explained more
on the Today Show Thursday morning I got
asked in an interview if I reads
negative things and I was like well I
think even going to her anymore it's not
like I've quit it like I still post on
Instagram d'Agosta Twitter I'm just not
gonna wake up and read something and be
like oh well that's rude
instead ed says he's focusing on the
positive I'm just saying as it as a
human being we always read the one
negative one antics with you know the
others and I don't want to do that and
the 26 year old has a lot to celebrate
of course of course his latest album
Divide went straight to the top of the
Billboard charts in March and two of the
tracks debuted in the top ten in the
same week a first for any artist and if
that weren't enough 12,000 fans lined up
to see him perform on today
with your body
[Music]